Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Let's try to assess the workflow of this piece
of work in the shortest possible form. The
input is images of cells, and the output of
the algorithm is a decision that tells us
which one of these are cancer cells.
As the pipeline of the entire experiment is
quite elaborate, we'll confine ourselves to
discuss the deep learning-related step at
the very end.
Techniques prior to this one involved adding
chemicals to blood samples.
The problem is that these techniques were
not so reliable, and that they also destroyed
the cells, so it was not possible to check
the samples later.
As the title of the paper says, it is a label-free
technique, therefore it can recognize cancer
cells without any intrusive changes to the
samples. The analysis happens by simply looking
at them.
To even have a chance at saying anything about
these cells, domain experts have designed
a number of features that help us making an
educated decision. For instance, they like
to look at refractive indices, that tell us
how much light slows down when passing through
cells. Light absorption and scattering properties
are also recognized by the algorithm. Morphological
features are also quite important as they
describe the shape of the cells and they are
among the most useful features for the detection
procedure.
So, the input is an image, then come the high
level features, and the neural networks help
locating the cancer cells by learning the
relation of exactly what values for these
high-level features lead to cancer cells.
The proposed technique is significantly more
accurate and consistent in the detection than
previous techniques. It is of utmost importance
that we are able to do something like this
on a mass scale because the probability of
curing cancer depends greatly on which phase
we can identify it. One of the most important
factors is early detection and this is exactly
how deep learning can aid us. To demonstrate
how important early detection is, have a look
at this chart of the ovarian cancer survival
rates as a function of how early the detection
takes place. I think the numbers speak for
themselves, but let's bluntly state the obvious:
it goes from almost surely surviving to almost
surely dying.
By the way, they were using L2 regularization
to prevent overfitting in the network. We
have talked about what each of these terms
mean in a previous episode, I've put a link
for that in the description box.
95% success rate with the throughput of millions
of cells per second. Wow, bravo. A real, Two
Minute Papers style hat tip to the authors
of the paper.
It is really amazing to see different people
from so many areas working together to defeat
this terrible disease. Engineers create instruments
to be able to analyze blood samples, doctors
choose the most important features, and computer
scientists try to find out the relation between
the features and illnesses. Great strides
have been made in the last few years, and
I am super happy to see that even if you're
not a doctor and you haven't studied medicine,
you can still help in this process. That's
quite amazing.
A big shoutout to Kram who has been watching
Two Minute Papers since the very first episodes
and his presence has always been ample with
insightful comments. Thanks for being around!
And also, thanks for watching, and for your
generous support, and I'll see you next time!